you want to know how Shawn Mendes his
underwear ended up in my hotel room uh
yes John Mayer sat down with Andy Cohen
on radio Andy I took a super random
stroll down memory lane sharing a story
that he deemed to be straight-up
clickbait and he was not lying guys it
all started when John and Shawn Mendes
were in the studio working on the song
liked to be you off Shawn's 2018
self-titled album totally normal right
well here's where it gets weird John
says mid studio sesh Shawn remembered
that he didn't have any more undies
naturally he says hey man do you think
you could like post mates underwear can
I post mates underwear and I said he's
like I just I'm out of underwear and I
said you don't have to post mates
underwear man I'll get you underwear so
I had my assistant go out and get Shawn
Mendes underwear he's a size medium by
the way do you think Shawn is going to
like the fact that John just revealed
his undies sighs I'm Chuck continue so
my assistant goes out and grabs him like
a bag full of medium boxer briefs and we
finished the song and he leaves the
studio and it doesn't take the underwear
with him then I take a bag back to my
hotel room of like 12 size medium
boxer-brief yes and they were in my
hotel room for like quite a while and I
was like that's for Shawn when I see him
I'm gonna get he got other underwear in
the interim but I was like that's an
interesting clickbait story someday
interesting is one word for it
sure anyhoo the chitchat wasn't all
boxer briefs John had a ton of sweet
things to say about Shawn he's just the
best I told him last night I said you
are so clear he's so clear-headed he's
so clear minded he's so earnest in the
right way he has a sense of humor in the
right way he's he's got what it takes to
go all really way the two had hung out
the night before John sit-down with Andy
and he revealed just how down-to-earth
his pal really is
I took the SUV last night and he Ebert
right I lost the best and the love is
mutual
et sat down with Sean in 2018 and he
opened up about his friendship with the
41 year old what was like working with
John well first of all was an honor to
have to have him work on the album and
he's just been so close throughout my
all of my album processes I've been able
to become only good friends with him
texting in music and him give me input
and now it's kind of he also sends me
stuff for input he asked for advice and
he asked for opinions and he wants to
learn and not let times go on without
him and that is so inspiring to me for
him you know I his ate not that he's old
or anything to ask me what I think about
his music is so nice it's a crazy thing
when your idols become your friends and
your peers and you just really kind of
connect that's a good friendship I love
this bromance and guys I hope they keep
making sweet music together post mated
undies and all of course will be here to
keep you in the know on all things John
and Sean so make sure to keep it locked
on et until next time I'm Hallie Stevens
bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]